and raise your right hand I will begin
by swore after months of investigation
the president wanted these two
investigations is that right correct
and that everybody knew it correct
testimony and acrimony witnesses were
able to establish any evidence of
bribery treason high crimes or
misdemeanors it all comes down to this a
vote in the House of Representatives on
whether to impeach Donald Trump what's
included are two very specific issues
one is abusing power by holding up duly
authorized foreign aid to an ally of the
United States and the second one is
basically contempt of Congress it
started with a phone call between
America's leader and Ukraine's president
Vladimir's zalenski that was a perfect
calm perfect to him impeachable to
democrats they claim America's leader
withheld aid to get a foreign power to
investigate Joe Biden for his own
political game they've also charged him
with obstructing Congress blocking
witnesses and refusing to hand over
documents how bad do you think it is
what Donald Trump is accused of this is
the worst impeachment that we have seen
in American history all the previous
impeachments were just about things that
happened inside the United States this
is the first one where the president is
using their very broad powers and
foreign policy for their own personal
political benefit this inquiry has
thrust career diplomats reluctantly into
the spotlight our Ukraine policy has
been thrown into disarray and shady
interests the word of the world over
have learned how little it takes to
remove an American ambassador who does
not give them what they want but not a
single Republican has said what the
president did is in p2p we saw the call
transcript and there's no conditionality
there was never awareness on the part of
the Ukraine that there was a delay in
aid and the Ukraine got the aid without
opening the investigation that
seems to be so troubling to Democrats it
doesn't matter if the deal was
consummated for it to be a problem the
problem is that the president tried he
tried to use his powers he tried to
withhold the aid to put this pressure on
szalinski we've been here before I did
not have sexual relations with that
woman
because people have got to know whether
or not their president is a trump the
Watergate Hotel embraces the legacy of
Richard Nixon's impeachment but this
inquiry is different we've known really
all the facts about the president's
actions from the beginning and so it
really is a question of how threatening
to democracy into constitutional order
is the president's behavior and and that
what that makes it different the
democrat-controlled house will likely
find against the president
but after Christmas the
republican-controlled Senate will
conduct a trial and very likely acquit
him twenty twenty years the Year America
decides the direction it wants to take
and the election is unlikely to be a
referendum on Donald Trump's impeachment
the economy health care and immigration
seem to matter far more to people right
now having said that the president
appears to view the investigation as a
chance to rally rather than recover
supporters impeachment is a double-edged
sword rarely used and for good reason
it's designed as a check on power but it
nullifies the will of voters for
Democrats it is indisputably a political
risk
Cordelia Lynch Sky News Washington